chacun sait bien qu un écolabel vous
comptez rester combien de temps à los
angeles monsieur cloud une seule yoka tu
saurais par hasard acquis bianca payer
son loyer et cheveux plaqués en arrière
vic bilh au pourquoi mon pote je cherche
ma soeur du regard
ambühl est important non n'y pas de sel
c'est bien le cas elle a un frère tu
m'as dit que bianca n'était plus un
problème bien le gars te raconter d'où
il venait
les caps flatte pas des taux de
criminalité les plus énormes de la
torture et pourquoi
bianca on est sorti
son frère est resté n'a aucune idée de
ce qu'il est capable de faire
il ne nous lâchera pas
c'est ta merde avec tout le monde
cherche quelque chose dans cette ville
hélas pour elle
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça va changer pour elle
maintenant
[Musique]
c'était ma soeur